[Musique]
envoyzen je me suis trompé de micro
monsieur non mais monsieur Mar vous me
supprimerez 500 francs sur mon cachet
c'est tout
[Musique]
quoi
roulant une Jaguar à est roulant un
playboy à son
[Musique]
volant qui serait tout contre
lui qui serit tout contre lui une fille
qui disait
Johnny on roule à près de
200 en roule près de 200 laisse tes
mains sur le volant oh
une de chevaux qui
passait une de chevaux qui passait le
chauffeur s'écrit mais c'est ma femme
dans cette
Jaguar ma femme dans cette Jaguar et
comme un fou il
[Musique]
démarre mais il glisse sur le sol
mouillé mais il glisse sur le sol
mouillé craque il est désintégré
[Musique]
ou Joh c'est mon mari a plus besoin de
nous
cacher a plus besoin de nous cacher
allez emène-moi
[Musique]
danserz uneire rou les PO à son volant
oh